britain said farewell to queen
elizabeth's husband
prince philip the 99 year old royal was
laid to rest at windsor castle
ian lee is there
a final salute at windsor castle
britain's armed forces said goodbye to
one of their own
prince philip planned every detail of
his funeral with military precision
down to the custom-made land rover that
carried his coffin
draped in his flag navy cap and sword we
have been inspired by his
unwavering loyalty to our queen
the duke of edinburgh leaves behind four
children and eight grandchildren
including princes william and harry
there's been tension between the
brothers since harry and megan's
bombshell interview with oprah
but the death of their grandfather
brought them back together
[Applause]
music from a small socially distanced
choir filled the chapel of 30 guests
mostly close relatives since windsor
castle sits
right in the flight path of london's
busy heathrow airport
during the funeral all planes were
diverted away from the area
out of respect the palace asked people
to stay away
too but many still came to remember the
royal
he could put people at their ease when
he talked to them
always made a joke the nation
fell silent to mark the passing of a man
who was always by the queen side
now for the first time in her nearly 70
years on the throne
she stands alone ian lee cbs news
windsor england